تواصل خوارزميات الانظمه المتطوره ابرزها
تشاد جي بي تي ترحم خاويفه كبيره التي
يمكن ان تؤثر هذه المره على مستقبل العمال
والاعمال في المؤسسات والمنصات الاعلاميه
موقع اكسيوس طرح تحولات محتمله يمكن ان
يشهدها قطاع الاعلام في المرحله المقبله
والتي ستكون كنتيجه حتميه للذكاء
الاصطناعي الذي سيساهم في تغيير نمط نقل
الاخبار بوتيره اسرع مما كانت عليه قبل
عقدين وفق اكسيوس ستكون معايير الخبره
والثقه والكفاءه والدقه في تقديم المعلومه
ابرز التحديات التي ستواجهها المؤسسات
الاعلاميه التي تتجه نحو صحافه الذكاء
الاصطناعي حيث سيرتفع الطلب على الخبره
المتخصصه والشركات الاعلاميه التي ستحقق
الازدهار وفق اكسيوس هي تلك التي تتكيف
بسرعه مع احتياجات المستهلكين سريعه
التغير والمؤسسات التي ستعمل ايضا على
محاربه المحتوى الوهمي وانشاء علاقات
مباشره مع المستهلكين خصوصا وان المستهلك
للماده الاعلاميه سيتمكن من الحصول على
نتائج بحث جيده باستخدام تقنيات شبيهه
والبحث ايضا عن مصادر اخبار اكثر امانا
وموثوقيه التطورات اذا تتسارع حيث كشفت
شركه ابحاث الذكاء الاصطناعي open اي اي
عن تحديث روبوت الدردشه
ليصبح قادرا على انشاء وتحرير النصوص في
حين تشير تقديرات لمؤسسه الصحافه الذكاء
الاصطناعي للبحث والاستشراف ان اكثر من
60% من المحتوى الاعلامي المنتج دوليا سوف
يعتمد على تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي في
السنوات الخمس القادمه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات